et on va démarrer cette troisième partie
avec un sujet alors là je sais ça vous a
révolté ce sujet les amis dans le 20
heures de france 2 on a appris que le
nombre de fausses cartes d'handicapés
avec explosé ces derniers mois les
fraudeurs s'en servirait pour éviter de
payer le stationnement posséder cette
carte de stationnement pour handicapés
permet de se garer gratuitement partout
en france sur des places réservées aux
invalides ou non résultat sur cette
avenue ce jour là sur dix voitures bars
et 9 cartes handicapés jacques gonzales
accepte pour nous d'échanger sa carte de
stationnement bien réelle contre une
contrefaçon plastique des agents de
contrôle arrive devant la voiture elle
vous paraît plutôt vrai look plutôt faux
celle là va pour moi je vois la data les
bonnes vielles numéro nous tombons bref
par d'amandes en vue conséquence de ces
fraudes pour jacques comme pour les
autres conducteurs handicapés se garer
est devenue une galère propre cible
c'est très très pénibles
le gouvernement a lancé l'an dernier une
nouvelle carte mobilité inclusion ou
cm10 censé être beaucoup plus difficile
à falsifier alors les fraudeurs faut le
rappeler tout de même et on leur
rappelle risque jusqu'à cinq ans de
prison et 75000 euros d'amendé ses
mimiques vous êtes scandale oui ouais je
suis scandalisé a calé à quel niveau de
dégueulasserie on peut être de faire
cette chose je suis désolé les places
handicapées elles sont pas là pour faire
joli elles sont pas là pour embêter les
gens
elles sont là pour des personnes qui en
ont vraiment besoin sont pas nombreuses
en plus elles ne sont pas très
nombreuses à y en a même pas assez je
trouve à mon sens je vais ressortir
cette fois ce que j'ai vu souvent passé
prends ma place prends mon handicap dans
ce cas là oui mais il faut lire pondéré
tes propos je pensais me les chemins je
t'adore messi parce qu'en fait il faut
recontextualiser la chose par exemple en
région parisienne lorsque vous circulez
en voiture vous prenez entre trente et
une trente minutes et une heure pour
trouver une place de stationnement et
quand vous trouver une place de
stationnement jouez bien vous devez le
payer à l'antre-2 euros 40 et 4 euros de
l'heure est à l'arrêt à l'art et bien
partir du moment où vous gagnez un smic
et de vous et que vous devez prendre
votre voiture pour aller travailler et
que vous êtes pressé je peux comprendre
que vous soyez tenté d'amender pas en
train d'investiguer le sait qu'on est
des fausses cartes handicap énorme si
ces jeunes gens non non non je comprends
en tout cas là c'est illégal il faut pas
le faire évidemment on va pas
l'encourager ici sur ce plateau
dans ce village en train de dire ça que
ya des gens qui le font mais qui ne se
garde pas forcément sur la place
handicapée qui le kin bien sûr
juste qui se garent oui voilà une façon
de place à mal mais oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous gagnez un smic
comment vous faites c'est un luxe de
celle ci a assuré aujourd'hui handicapé
ils sont riches encore mais subit un
rapport mais tu racontes n'importe quoi
c'est pas un problème d'argent c'est un
problème de comportement d'une façon
générale citoyen à place de quelqu'un
qui est handicapée s'est même pas tu
truande pour pas payer un pack mixer
tutu prend la place d'un handicap et moi
je dis que le problème c'est que de
toute façon ils n'ont pas réglé la
situation ça il faudrait grave est
carrément les voitures et trouver un
système pour pas falsifié parce que les
gens ils sont enfin ça comme correcte et
effectivement je voudrais surtout plus
de place en fait ce sera que c'est ça
qui règlera le problème et puis surtout
besson ici à un abbé vraiment mais a
payé entre 2 et 4 euros de l'heure c'est
pas possible quand tu gagnes 1200 euros
net par mois n'était pas possible
damian pardonnez-moi mais rien ne
justifie la sensibilité et le fait de
prendre une fausse carte handicapées est
alors non mais je peux entendre vous
dites que vous dites qu'ils sauvegardent
pas forcément est ce que je ne crois pas
du tout sur les places handicapées et
quand bien même il se garaient pas sur
les places handicapés ils sont en train
de truander donc voilà oui bien sûr je
suis d'accord évidemment prendre la
place d'un handicapé qui mesure une
place qui lui est réservé je trouve ça
effectivement dégueulasse normalement
c'est une pièce qui lui est réservé mais
là c'est quand même mais regardez au
niveau de la chaussée sur des places qui
vous sont réservées à vous quand vous
êtes valide et vous avez effectivement
cette crise est en veilleuse ça me
choque pas pardon mais quand c'est
tellement cher de ce qu il faut c fausse
carte juste pour se garer sur les places
qui ne sont pas déplacés à temps mais
emilie tu te rends pas compte du budget
que c'est que ça coûte de se stationner
dans une grotte pour comprendre ce que
tu dis mais oui mais damien n'a pas
compris que c'est une ce sont des
fausses cartes ce sont des gens valides
qui créent des fosses pour justement se
garer sur des places que tu peux pas
dire que c'est normal il y à 2,3
millions de personnes en handicap en
france dans des fauteuils roulants qui
ne peuvent pas se garer
parce que toi tu penses que c'est normal
en tant que valide de te créer une qu'un
parce que tu n'as pas les moyens ou tu
n'as pas assez de temps pour te garer
c'est très grave
moi je pense que cinq 5 ans de prison ce
n'est pas assez pour ces gens qui
fraudent yeux qui sont qu'ils font quand
même une faute très grave et en plus de
ça je pense que le synchro non c'est pas
super quand c'est pas mal quand même
c'est pas ces figures de 75000 euros
vers nation quand même en plus et je
pense que leur karma ça à illzach karma
son et des générations leurs enfants
leurs petits-enfants leurs arrières
petits-enfants oui on mange ils vont
manger très grave rigoler vraies ou
fausses cartes surtout ne vous garez pas
n'importe où voilà c'est tout ça va
arriver normalement
mais qui sans générer au téléphone mais
aussi bien sûr et maggie chauvet très
bien un petit peu de mal avec
l'articulation mais ça allait